i visualized this for myself when i was
selling copiers door-to-door i had a
very clear vision of what my life was
going to be like and i encourage
everyone to do it
take a snap photo of what success looks
like for you are you how many employees
do you have how much are you making
where do you live
are you sitting at a table with world
leaders are you standing on a stage in
new york city giving a speech and hold
on to that that snapshot and you will
subconsciously start to make decisions
that get you there and so my snap photo
for myself when i was going door-to-door
to sell copiers was to be self-employed
invent a product that i could sell to
lots of people and not just one copier
to each person and create a business for
myself that would continue to fund
itself if i wasn't present i wanted
money to be generated without me having
to be there i was that specific in my
vision want to be happy build a life not
just a business hey it's evan carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how you
can activate the power of visualization
enjoy
[Music]
rule number two have faith with steve
vai it's good to have a goal
and wherever you set your goal
you have to have the um the patience the
discipline and the faith
to break it down and take it step by
step even if your goal is to be able to
play a beatles song on the beach
that that's a particular goal and you
need to break it down
and build and have faith and have them
visualize yourself doing it
you know and if you visualize yourself
doing it
and you stick to your
your guns there's nothing in the world
that can stop you rule number three
realize that you can do better with
james cameron what finally attracted uh
me to film in such a definitive way was
it was the only place i could reconcile
the need to tell stories
and to work in a visual art medium
and
the desire to understand things at a
technical technological level in my
fascination with with engineering and
technology i watched a couple of really
bad directors work and i saw how they
com they completely bought [ __ ] up and
and missed the visual opportunities of
the scene when we had put things
in front of them as opportunities set
pieces props and so on and they had
these great actors to work with and they
just blew it
and there was a moment where i said
i may not be very good at this but i
know i'm better than that guy and that
was kind of a critical moment because
when you realize that you can at least
be better than somebody else who's
already doing it then you can visualize
yourself doing the job also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four don't lose sight
with steph curry for me i mean yeah you
visualize where you want to be
and what you want to accomplish and
you kind of get lost in the process of
day-to-day you know grinding it out
working
pulling all ours if you have to um you
know that this it's just about
not losing vision and not losing sight
of what you're what you're trying to
accomplish no matter what hurdles you
have to go through so
um i think that
kind of relates to whatever you're doing
uh whatever um
you know major you've chosen or
what you're interested in so for me and
basketball and
it's about you know visualizing whether
you write it down put it on the wall do
something with what your goals are and
get lost in the process of day-to-day
grind day-to-day getting better every
single day
asking questions aligning yourself with
people that have been through it before
that
that are experienced and leaning on that
advice and
just trying to outwork
the next person and that's the biggest
thing rule number five have a positive
approach with tony hawk if you're
convinced that you're going to fail or
fall or get hurt
that will come to fruition because
that's what you're visualizing i never
visi you know i was willing to get hurt
along the way but i didn't visualize
myself getting hurt along the way
um and i think that's what
that's what
stops a lot of people and that's really
what separates a lot of people from from
being
world champions or from being as good as
they can because they they stop at some
point saying oh no i
i
am not capable of this or i'll probably
get hurt doing this
and if you approach anything with that
hesitation you're going to fail
i always approached it like
this is going to work i'm going to
figure this out
even if it takes me
hundreds of attempts
and i wasn't
you know the the idea of falling getting
back up again
that didn't really bother me at all rule
number six envision good things with
sierra i've always believed in myself
you know i've always been a big dreamer
and um i can definitely say a lot of
things that i dreamed of have come true
and a lot of things that i've envisioned
to come true and so
yeah i've always envisioned all the cool
things that are happening happening
and and it's happened and then some so
yeah that's cool and rule number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is visualize the winning
feeling with maria sharapova i
definitely see this this r everyone
seems to have this aspect of rushing
like rushing to get to the next step and
rushing to make
a certain amount of money and
when i when i think of goals
i don't necessarily think of specifics
i just think of more feelings of how i
would feel when i get to that what is my
success and how does that feel like
um instead of saying okay i want to
i want to win this amount of titles and
i want to win this amount of grand slams
or i want to earn this amount of money
um
i think that always i think more of the
feeling how am i going to feel when i
win match point i visualize it i embrace
that feeling and i carry it with me like
you visualize it
all the time or in the moment i think
moments and and
i think it always comes when you least
expect it sometimes you can be on a
on a run sometimes those long plane
rides where
you know it's sunset and and it's just
you and you've been traveling and you're
going home and you have no one around
you just yourself on the flight it's
just a bunch of hundreds of strangers
next to you and you have this moment
where
um you start thinking of why you're
doing this why are you lonely why are
you in this position and you think of
what you've already done to get there
and
where you would like to see yourself go
so it those moments always come at a
different i don't i don't sit down and i
think okay right now i'm gonna visualize
um the feeling that i might have when i
just win a tournament or
yeah but i definitely i think it's
important to i when you say things or
you know when a friend of mine says
something negative and i was like don't
put that in the universe don't put that
out there yeah i do believe in that
there's some sense of um
truth in that because it also comes with
then you carry it with that attitude you
know when someone says something
negative you usually see their attitude
change and
um
shows up in your body and your energy
yeah and i
mean i for sure do that as well and i
have my moments and
but the faster you acknowledge it and
realize it the faster you can move on
can you this is another thing i like on
the show if it's possible like people
have been willing to go there i'm not
suggesting it's just a little bit of
pressure but not too much
share one of those ten goals
i know you got some big ones and knows
if knows a fine answer but no is it fine
no no no no no no no no so so one of
those 10 goals that you read every day
it's easy
one of the 10 goals is i will uh
i will get down to 170 that's my
fighting weight and you know after like
i said the medicine
and and the things have uh i've had to
figure things out but um i will get down
to 173 pounds by uh
is april 15th and i will do this by
drinking eight bottles eight eight
glasses of water a day not eating any
fried foods meats and not eating after
six pm unless it's after a workout
i will also put in 10 000 steps a day
and in return for this health i'll be
able to stay around in my daughter's
lives and walk them down the aisle
incredible so what happens is when i get
to
april 15th
i can be 180 doesn't matter i reset the
goal for another six months but you have
to visualize yourself after when you do
because you start because then then i
then i write then i say meditate and
what you have to visually
look at is me walking my daughters down
the aisle be careful yeah you have to
visualize it because something like
losing weight for the sake of losing
weight it's hard motivation i think tony
tony does a great job with this tony
robbins like how can you associate
something insanely positive with the
results of that goal and see yourself in
that moment yeah i think that that's
powerful thank you for sharing that
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to go even deeper into the power of
visualization check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there
that's what that's what people don't
understand man if people see
the end result
remember that guy saying my god man i
can't believe it i've just done i put
everything